today we're talking about the new
benefits for getting certified more
podcasts and improving Google cloud with
your feedback I'm Chloe and welcome to
this week in Cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news
we are thrilled to announce some new
Google Cloud certification benefits that
reinforce our commitment to Google Cloud
certified individuals and our Global
sustainability strategy check out the
blog for a look at what's to come for
our certified Community from a digital
toolkit to sustainable options for
merchandise
we recently created a site for all of
Google Cloud's podcasts making it easier
than ever for you to catch up with
Google Cloud that's where you can find
all of your favorites plus any new shows
we've created check it out for the
latest releases from the cloud security
podcast Google Cloud SRE podcast Google
Cloud Reader and the Google Cloud
platform podcast
ER experiences are critical to user
experience researchers at every level of
developing Google Cloud products whether
it's migrating a user to Google Cloud
helping them understand it once they are
there or delving into using cloud
services one thing is clear learning
from people who use Google cloud is
fundamental head to the blog to learn
more about how we're taking your
feedback and making Google Cloud better
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud